[Applaudissements]
car en seconde noce était minable je
vous dit merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le métronome là bas mesdames
dites moi que vous faites pas comme ça
on aurait dit un vieux film de marc
dorcel
vous avez deux sacrés beaux yeux j'ai
très envie de sentir
[Rires]
elle aurait dit vous avez la peau bienne
lucian aux os mais je vois que que les
vielles bushiste vous l'aurez pas
[Applaudissements]
regardez maintenant madame je sais que
vous accompagnez je suppose que ces
jeunes gens ils ont besoin d'apprendre
ce qu'est la vie un jour ou l'autre il
vous faudra bien qu'ils se marient
là-bas dunkerque
alors regardez les enfants et n'est
qu'une seule technique de drague c'est
la technique jean michel mr 40 secondes
top chrono
bonjour le film a dit que vous appelez
d'hadès je suis désolé me dire vous
importuner mais si j'étais pas venu vous
parler j'en serais voulu pendant
plusieurs semaines on voit là je suis
désolé je vous apporte une certaine mans
voilà j'avais envie qu'on discute un peu
si ça vous gêne pas trop vous déjà eu
des expériences souvent malheureuses
parfois heureuse où je tenais pas votre
passé mais je tape
en tout cas vous m'attire énormément
vous êtes déjà très belle je connais pas
donc je peux mal je m'arrête que
physique
mais voilà je suis désolé encore si je
peux vous laisser mon numéro si vous
avez la gentille
ah bon
alors normalement on est censé s'arrêter
là mais je sais que beaucoup serez déçu
ce